[Music]
celebee
bg 2
th
tee
dee
[Music] Hmm
[Music]
Only follow the path of 4 and take pride in the panter
to determine the power of the mask
.
dee
yeah yeah yeah [music] [applause] pony noone on db Tanaka n one catcher's tgs wipe
marnie and bad study up tuning
boo boo starmen special wa rex
voodoo
maker prestige 4 b
4 use notification Daisukesho
usa noa per  Ale em up candy wear hiro a
mission
voodoo
lure
rsr 4 nj narai ah ah
usa re not to do
Can you see us d Special is
Vision c Shorts
Return ball Please keep everyone at the camera shop jerseys Yeah Yeah Yeah
voodoo bass
[Music]
[Applause]
voodoo style for your
lg baboon isn't in a hurry
s chan
carerra rearea Arles terese
voodoo
ah ah ah well endear cap 4 star ender ender he roma genon junior Kumabe niime nossa nossa boo boo du boarder ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
this means to
do te park sushi
It's a beat party. You
don't have 8 to see.
[Music]
Boo Boo sp.
us all ears 4 a  sore to do
alea
arerea + af 0 race ame recast 4 arenberg
to do mall
usdx  Power
us army er
pas a pas step 5 the leaders ah
bearded join to do
rear derailleur
make sure you do hair on rord to do x
wide this
nx ada yeah yeah for example
this terrifically
2.2x cab all gachiped game 81 pon medium xp
booby  ester buster wader goo do purity seems to be
johnmas menge indexes bbj turbo bee
vale a pena to do
me to do
soon for ads moulay s wear
voodoo
us army mirrorless
root screw change cover blur
ipi 5 ab erb sex ober
voodoo
patagonia best 4  Go to sad version Place Butcher Kin-chan Bake Sero
Tube Yamabun
Building 4 a
Hey Papa Pair Off to on can she refused to do
n Bill Good
Prince seen to do
Mets Work Various-
per hour Mare Stars March Blue
noreason x  Week eno matano I
can't say that I'm wearing earth juicy s guest performance Harvey can't say bounding
up ring spare
ras card bota banter x wiggle away
ear deinterlace
hooded deeds and pure takuchan winice
emperor next by nector as charburger
pw cab e to do no n rb
special  Edition rr 3 ban degree fahrenheit
voodoo
ber 4
polar to do
foley editor pro for certain dare to do
alpha
m no
boo boo sp wing gel pedicure
own ran defense jra clip s have a good to me to
do
win US rice bd 4 a cha
use our
nmb I'm doing it in the year
usage and we are
it forcibly tune live well
today parise good good good vote the reason frp sugar
weak quadiva there oss ah
[music]
parent pocharori big  Eating burger
us eno
Poa Kutin Kuru
Ivo Shogi Dam Option Hardware 1 day Devil Bear
you do spa Masu Gala me to do Bar Car After all it's
ai
Ekkowa den o snb
usage iphone
pei Border
you do as dpi Fit powder  It's the same from the border
release, but it's also possible Manabe Emo j Party You Can usa
Nome Character anpon opa
Energy Mona Floor Makeup 5 way Paprika Huang
ipod Slowly 5 download Power Up 7 a son
Super Caro Opened and increased source usa era Blogger
aw Duros
Boober Parless Marie
nestor examen re so d 4 voodoo Assertive
buster do do do
voodoo Wow,
I wonder if it's a fat temperature ne
Aqua Happy 0
Downliner set ab other busking Logger Sumo chasing
power I'm one song  1 star bows is also good for ether place eater
dls plus paria
date game
voodoo
edos remasters os blue dua
are
Why Kei is the inspection case Aoi Shoin Aki-chan circuit
teraterm Overpercy to do
we are n babo r
[Music]
voodoo sakino Ale
emea Aalen 4 xp e r
A
voodoo doco
Bartime air
voodoo loox xeno Ale Arthur
voodoo
remon fosters Faceway
Byon j
usb Good Arles Campaign Wale ah ah
use arrandale Cliver Special Edition oborete
Ann 5 e seiso border none nea Pure Star Wow
temas ear bondage Ahre
Statue Sakura andme 5 p 6 Ah Ah Good
dere
xeno  folder Action or Transport meer Game Overboard Game
Name 5 Special Edition Do You Do
fe Hey Cha Kim Good
adele arbeit Foley
Baby Stay
Delivery Company Zazu a 4 is lonely Yes Knitting Tsubo
am ende Make Eifare derstandard you are
lazy ass to do  Fish
imran led Senior tasting i swear
rarirure hangeng d Game ordered Writer
Killer
I think I've used up the folder name and route I think I've already used it up
.  I wanted to be a little different. I
said in English f I was happy, but I was able to hear the spirit. Yama-chan, I caught only my feelings.
How was your information
? From here, we are broadcasting from 8 pm on the 1st and 3rd Wednesday of every month.
Thank you for your
cooperation
.
There is plenty of game information and guest talks.
I'd like to get a lot of excitement, but I think the remote supporters are also preparing well.
Isn't it great? It's better to keep the box out. I have it. It's really amazing. Matt-
san's feelings
.  I'm wearing a t-shirt.
How about everyone? I understand that you'll be connected like this.
Thank you for dancing if you can do it.
It's going to be done-It
's a long time to say that you can connect by repeating this, press Yokoi
Do you guys connect?
Thank you.
I think there are people who have various shapes every time.
Thank you very much. I hope you can take your finger off
and return to the Nanase position.
Thank you. Today,
I would like you to stay with me until the end. Thank you.
I won't
do it. Well, the sound special edition information of Devil May Cry 5
came out, but
I think that Ayana-chan, the assistant on tv 3rd Wednesday, stood up, of course,
but that's right.  I think it's a mourning, so I'd like everyone to catch up a little. If it's
not that legendary mode,
I can already see Ayana-chan's face playing that with that rugged face
.  If I try to challenge myself with the feeling that I'm fighting, I
'm screaming, isn't it
? I love it so crowded
. I regret not being here.
I think it's supposed to be, but
let's all wait for future updates. The Devil May Cry 5 Special Edition campaign is currently underway
.
Chocolat, thank you for your details. Yes,
now.  Devil May Cry 5
Special Edition Release Commemorative twitter Campaign is underway
Devil May Cry Series Official Account Follow and post Devil May Cry Underbar If
you retweet the campaign target tweets, 55 people will
win the original quo card by lottery In
addition, Kotobukiya's comment course  Figure brand
art fx 1/8 par juice figure wins one person by lottery from before
Comment Course application method is also the same as Devil May Cry series official account
Follow Devil May Cry Underbar jp
Hash tag tmc 5 se
Next generation hardware  Please tweet the comments you expect from the devil may cry 5 special edition.
This recruitment period is until 13:00 on Monday, September 28th tomorrow. If you have
n't applied yet, please join the campaign.
Thank you for your participation.
Well, from here, we will send you related information on
Devil May Cry 5 Special Edition.  The
polo shirt has
an embroidery on the left chest that is inspired by the three main characters, Otoro Dantei v. Although it is a
one-point design, it has a cool finish that anyone who knows the game can tell at a glance which character it
is.
This polo shirt will be delivered by the end of October
. Yes, here is a sample
hut. Yes, there will be a mark coming to a regrettable place.
It is
finished in a cool design parker with the weapons printed on the back in monotone
. The delivery of this parker is scheduled for October 1st or
later. Thank you for your polo shirt and parker.
But the article is a robbery. If there is
one that is really good for temperature control, the pen lens is
cool. The back is right. Yeah, it's
one point in front. It's simple and I'm fashionable.
Thank you for your patience. Yes, please continue to watch this video.
[Applause]
[Music]
Yes, Dante, a popular character in the Devil Make Rye series.  Is now available in an
astonishing 1/2 scale with transcendental quality.
This statue reproduces the realism of the skin in the eastern part of silicon, aiming for a presence that seems to have jumped out of the game
.
As for the population, Hitomi uses a custom-made doll eye.
Furthermore, we will use cloth such as synthetic leather and noodles for the costumes, and we will leave a mark to all the fans
.
It is on display at the 7th Prime 1 Studio Gallery Shop in Shinjuku Marui Annex, so if you are interested,
please come visit
us. It will be on sale a little later, but
please make a reservation once the order start time is decided.  Don't forget
Yes,
Lily is woven into the studio again, and I'm playing it at home. This is a little bit here, but I
wonder if you can understand the size is
about this size.
I took a picture with me a while ago, but it's almost the same height as me,
it's white hair and this isn't it, but
that's right
, that texture is
amazing.  It might be a mustache or a beard with a beard.
What kind of thing
is being reproduced? It's going to
change. It's amazing.
That's right, what kind of
coat hem 9
isn't surprised by Hon Momoya? Dirty inside the pants
Yes, there was a carp Yes, there was a beard, and so is the dirt and shoes, but to
put it simply, there is a possibility that Grandpa and Grandma will talk to you.  Yes, of
course, it's a personal opinion, but
it seems possible
,
so I'm surprised that it's going to be a crime prevention here
. It's amazing. Yes, please check it out. Heim
I want it to be in the form of a deviation
. This isn't it when you look at Hashino.  Capcom Star Osaka,
an antenna shop that sells Capcom goods,
will open at Shinsaibashi Parco in November 2020. This Capcom strike is the
first in the Kansai region following Store Tokyo, which opened in 2019 at Shibuya Parco.
Limited goods that can only be purchased here are scheduled to appear one after another.
This time Capcom has prepared a Devil May Cry 5
dmc motor home type pouch.
The latest information on the store including this product will be released at any time in the future.  So please look forward to the follow-up report.
Motor home type pouch Hmm
Boober
This is important because
it's so easy to put in, I wonder if I should put in a make
pouch.  If
you live in the Kansai region, please look forward to it because it's cute and cute like this.
And another Capcom character cafe
Capcom taxable Aeon Lake Town  The store
will hold a collaboration of Devil May Cry 5 from December 18th to January 28th
. This time, we will release a rough sketch of the collaboration illustration that Garson dressed as sleeping ahead
of this time.  It seems that we are working hard to meet everyone's expectations
. Please look forward to it. It
was related information for devil may cry 5 special edition.
Yes, thank
you.  Will tell you about the Rockman x type that was announced the other day
. Please see here first
.
[Music]
Yeah Yeah Yeah [Music] [Music] [Applause] [Music] Yes
The latest work Rockman x with a new world view in the x series will
appear in the smartphone app.
This work is a full-scale 2d side-scrolling action,
and not only Rockman x fans but also those who like side-scrolling action
Of course you can also enjoy
this Rockman x quite a lot of Rockman x series games  It
is set in a cyber world called Deep Prob where the
data is stored. The game data stored in the cyber world deep log is in a messed up state due to a bug of unknown cause
, and the player suddenly appeared to the
navigator Noriko.  Guided from the real world to the world of
deep log The story is about manipulating characters appearing in Rockman x such as x and zero of the hunter program that can be reproduced with deep log,
defeating irregular data and aiming to restore game data.
Yes, of course, there are plenty of replay elements.
Limited time events
, co-op play with friends, boss challenges to face direct death, and other users
to compete for the clear time of the stage that switches every day
.  We have prepared a lot of elements that can not be rude even if you play real-time battles
with users.
For more information about this
, you can check it on the official website of Rockman x 2nd.
Yes, we are currently conducting a pre-registration campaign.  Among them, Apple's Apple store google
play store
And Rockman x A lot of items that can be used in the app according to the number of registrations of official twitter are
given as a gift, and the final goal
is 660,000 Rockman.
As a double chance, 20 people
who have followed Rockman x quite official twitter during this pre-registration period will be
given a lottery of
Rockman x quite original wireless headphones x model
.  We will continue to carry out the latest information and various campaigns, so please register in advance
and follow us on twitter.
Yes, it's already over 40,000,
so it's almost time for Miya Maro.  I'm going to go sooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo.
Chan Before going to the next introduction, this Capcom tj slive
2020 Campaign Information I would like to tell you about this as well. We are
continuing to carry out the campaign today as well as yesterday.
First of all, Monster Hunter Rise Monster Hunter stories 2
Biohazard Devil May Cry and Street Fighter Community  After
following the twitter account,
Capcom tgs Live 2020
will be a new standard for digital gifts for a total of 10 people, 2 from each account by lottery from those who tweeted with the hash tag ctl 2020.
We are running a campaign to win 10,000 yen of Warcard Pay. The
deadline is for those who tweeted by 23:59 on Sunday, September 27,
until the end of today's program.  We will announce three keywords somewhere in the
We will also carry out a campaign to win yen.
This deadline is until 9 am on Monday, September 28, tomorrow.
This is a pretty good body. I got angry even if I didn't put
in the app.  It's easy to use just by displaying the code.
Yes, please apply and get it
. Yes, I'm going to have the first key word, Mr. Ki, announce it today. Yes, everyone.
First of all, this is
the run.
Good
capcom. I think it's okay
to put anything in it. It's disadvantageous. We will put out three keywords by the end of today's program,
so please continue to watch until the end.
Thank you.  -Because I'm old, everyone will be waiting for this
stage.
Thank you very much, Mr. Tsukamoto. Thank you, Mr. Hirai, Chocolat. 1009 Mecha Hirai Be #
La-Everyone renapur 4 matera strangest you can we be
to do
[applause]
[music]
buster worst
rangers are yo  u doing
sa Creamy is Beverly sim app relian uc Curler
Eline peres Rudus Marching
Thank you.
Buber Leather
Fefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
FEFE FE
FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE  Smile of a-bee
pe other services for ads Checker sa
Displaywear
4 people
Detailed watch fan
Beijing Burning
Yes Safe j
Go Wow
Eat Tofu
Paraso they Take a nap Hahaha
[Music]
[  Applause]
Wear
Clipping So Pairway-
Well, Epipen Iska was powdered hamster at 45 of summer, and I
'm still processing
it.
I'm going to people
First of all, I can love the path to school Way
of Boyne 4 minutes 100 kinds
me the four s tee
[Music]
Let's answer the Etsu cast
Efechasuna window Shabu Wei
Wow boo boo ster dere noream Sto  Lee deserter as to do in
Oh there was a
Hugh man diligent tower 1 renegades rebase Oh perdre
event produced game
What a good buddy new work
Aza Dummy Star Mail Edge Fisher King Shall
I think I'll take away Across Benz Rose
to do app ps game  see
Greens
Wow Weblogless Used Refrigerating 6 Black Men asora Version s
flower
render tales Moulape Teppei
Isn't it the best money? Pub you doing i Motion Long Hours
7 tragedy
-Wow Chris orders from 7 e class e ne
Abaato roden ender ender club good
rpe ale nba guga-su-o-es-a-ra-
This work can be said to be another bank
voodoo falling
Buberre
girls love  Regards, I chose it.
Re you doing re you doing
ah
ss free w Talking You might buy it with hydrogen sir name
bes same as are you doing
maybe maybe 625 Kita horse racing and aiff view  4 f Mation will
increase
Well, that's on the right
side Powers
Boo Boo Good
derenno Allen Free Game Award
Applause Ah That Smile
decopei is also a place where you can go to the home of Part 2 properly
s 4 nu
google doodle re campus you do s secure
user paster 4 jo
perm game endorse
[music]
us rendered ear earphones
swati 20th anniversary sorede
Today also 25 years ago taron us rd 4th and 9 do
voodoo lar
p 4
Boo Doo's 25-year-old type e ne to do so are ready mu mib semester ender ender ender Penfadi tero
Weefy fish It's
just a decent old rosa life a.
italiano Back polygon I want to lose a little more
15th anniversary
uso rear center
rendered e to do
Well, fans like this image
so re lus andrade Aalen re to do Shon r
Thank you very much.
-Su # dp rx Game Power Chin
chen lee
Thank you very much during the fence stay, but
thank you for watching the heater management
gun planner chair.
No Abe Chairma bully I want to let the owner use various things.
Utuber circumstances Everyone really well
voodoo
voodoo ocd reste Thank you
car for today
boo boo s big boo
rearea cerasus to do
Yes everyone good evening reflected
Fefefu
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Xilinx
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  It ’s FEFE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE
FE
Ahhhhh,
use to do
deuse are rebone
use
car Produced by rearea Aalen b 4 ad genon
wings over n g o m e
h
Go
to Boo Boo Leon in a suit and Boo Boo Boo Boo lele
ee The floor is asaberu scare
Introduced in rebeccarebee Ale Pure mom
Formation Guardy
rw saree Rain
eaw
Doiday Guam vivi Thank you for Miss Kobe
Boo Boo sapere
Errare Victory w do Wedge information and characters that appear Fuoha winner
usb pd
erj rape Ah person paneer
50 years for Joypan air and ip cineast is the first biohazard
dare ni per wings to do as you do char
ja sapper Webber pearl pierce mashiko
re re re re re poster ni
pinker Abe reproduction web mation figure j sequel tamasan cg perso weed day
ran  Pr render ende American English ah
4 x special talk das ende Arthur
How was the information about Resident Evil Village?
From here, I'm Capcom tv mc America Zarigani Hirai, and
yes, my assistant Chocolat Ikeda will send it to
you. Thank you. Thank you.
It's not just two of us.
Before you came to these people who appeared earlier, Mr. Hirai,
right? Remote supporters,
why don't you talk to me once?
Thank you
everyone yet.  Are you sleepy? How are you guys?
Thank you for your energy. Thank you for taking the cheese. I'm sorry I skipped the script
.
I'd like to introduce myself here. Yeah, it's been a
long time ago. It's the same as the producer who was in the village about four times. You came to the
beat producer.
The name should come out
Yes Everyone, good evening, I'm Kanda, who looks like a biohazard village producer
. Thank you. Thank you.
And
I'm 5 minutes. I'm a cram school producer.
Thank you.
It's from here, it's a
regrettable city, I'd like to make a promised village, but I'd like
to liven up the talk about the truth,
but I can do it.
Well, yes, that previous work
7 was a concrete house, isn't it?
This time,
the village is a good stage beyond this house, so I think it will be a little more and
more stronger than the ingredients.  I think it's
one case. Zucca It looks like a village, but I'm really looking forward to seeing
the face behind it or the
same product. This is the video of that announcement and
that pv fishing that was released this month.  I think you'll understand if you can, but
after all the quietness is that kind of atmosphere where various things are lurking in
Kanmura.  I think that you can feel that scale feeling.
Yes, by all means, that kind of
Murao As a starting point, this village
Yes Yes Biohazard Village is that picture story game
Movie is also in progress  It's high in the shape of a game,
but I'd like to hear a lot of information, but
I'd like to say it, but it seems like it's not there.
I'd like to talk, but it's Honmachida station,
isn't it kind?
No, I
'd like to hear more information little by little in the future. I'm
looking forward to it.
I would like you to come to the troll. It's an oasis of the hearts of the dollars
. I'm a child of a laughing arts house. Thank you.
Thank you very
much. I'm going to be an oasis. I'm going to introduce myself a little on Twitter while I'm re-co-starring a delusion that has changed suddenly.
I'm sick, but I'm not sleepy at all 0 It's okay, it's a lie,
I heard that it's a lot of advanced games
.
I'm here, but it's already an official house.
Non-channel a I've played a lot of horror games with the Empress and it's already a big
excitement.  I'm supposed to have this pie,
but I'm Natsumi, so I'm not threatening to see glory with my friends at my friend's house before I enter here today.
It's not like Hey
Joe, but
I'm addicted to it when I start playing
biohazard, and I feel like this will never end until I clear it at the end.
Thank you for letting me play 4 games.
No, I was really
born and started from surly 3 A certain 5 rem It was regrettable I went
ah ah ah well, of course this  How many people are watching it? It's a little
awesome, isn't it? It's like that, it's not good.
Suma-san, it's a creature or something weird
.  I wonder if I'll do it as I want.
That's right
.
[Laughter]
Ross Also, everyone is enjoying the play
. Ice Yes, it's also a horror, but it's fun
to watch. After all, gorgeous people are looking at this area quite severely.
Well then, I can change, I just watched the channel
Rui Yazawa It's dangerous, I'm a king I'm really such people and other
senior members I'm already building a game distribution like this  If
you come, I'll respect you for a long time, right? Yes, there are almost a lot of carp next to me
.
It's connected to the number of registrants.
No, everyone is having fun.
No,
there aren't many people who are playing with such a
passion.  It's been 25 years since then,
so it's a good idea to collect the goods. It's a very long period of time. Yes,
as I mentioned earlier, 141 works have
been released.
here 2.9 here till I'm glad I'm a little deck lure 4
pattern continuous cg It should be a drama Mayo
infinite I'm really looking forward to darkness, but yes yes hazard r I'm
satisfied with that Leon and Claire of stomachache, so please look forward to it as well.
I think it's amazing. It's amazing
because you
can see it in the distribution, so it's like the distribution that his mouth is distributed at the same time and everyone
sees it.  How is it?
No, I'm Beppu messed up  It was strong.
It ’s a tank, but it ’s a pleasure to discover it, is n’t
it? It ’s great, I think it ’s
your upheaval.  Mr.
Katsune Well, only the set flies, yeah on day
There aren't any spoilers there, so everyone already knows
how much I can say, oh yeah, I don't know the line, right
?  Didn't you say the point? I think it's important to say it, but
it's okay. Kanda Producer's glasses are a little scary
.
Please do your best. It's a little more nest. I'll be able to operate it in a little more.
I'll be able to eat more and more
.
That's
right, it feels like I've really entered the world of this world's first nest game
more than ever.
I'm really looking forward to the ending because I can reach the goal.
Yes
, even if it's Madam, it's
still like how to collect it with a fishing
cocker.  I understand at the stage
I understand I understand how it will be collected and disposed of
To put it the other way around, I wish we were like that at that time
. I'm watching warmly
. People who have cleared the temperature bio are really like that. Everyone is really warm to those who are playing now.
Even if it's a comment, do your best,
or don't lose.
It's kind of like Rukayo, it's really kind. It's really kind. I'm really commenting. I'm
almost Mr. Kano, but he doesn't tell me messed up
.
Let's see, yes, when the cat is really clogged, I can talk to you about
the year. I got a hint, so it's a little fun prefecture play
.
I'm looking forward to the stains, but it's supposed to be even more steep, and the level is getting higher and higher. It's
evolving, isn't it
?  I
hope you can expect it. First of
all, it's the 7th floor. Please clear the ingredients properly. Yes, then you'll be with your friends
. From there,
it's heavy snow.
I hope you can wait for the bottom of the story. Next, I would like to continue to deepen the story about Biohazard Village,
but I hope you can see the
video horse making video called here till
and feel the charm of the village.  Thank you for your
cooperation. There is always a whiper that seems to have been built up to that point. There is always a
terrifyingly beautiful village b who
will do it.
Roman numerals
were included in the wrong design when making 7 That brother market is a sequel to Bio 7 Jammer Seto,
which
is interesting and not wet, but this technique village will be
m and the current director is standing, but the
main character
Will be the same discrete winters from July 6 il 7
This by Hazard Village, but
it will be a complete inconsistent work of the Nissan scenario.
However, it is the same as walking 7 whether it is the same as 7 or not. It is
not the same re engine but has gained development, and of
course I am making full use
of Arin-chan's picture
rope with many matchmakers.
I'm doing my best at the same time as our development team brother to be the second place overflowing.
Yes,
I'll do the flashing care separately.
Audi a 6
e Please have me Repeat on Market Barrow
Yes Suit 0 I want to say various things this time.  However, I
don't stop for a moment because it seems like I'm going to enter the valley I put in
. I feel that it's the power of the machine
.  That's a spec machine range,
so we're trying to make the most of it with no talk. Let's meet that Japan.
Well, including the rate receive,
but
that part is that very
powerful and Fumiya probably feels like that, and this time it will
also lead to that direct user's gameplay experience.  3 dp
Audio or something like that I think it's really fun to swell that picture I feel
that it will be a work of the next generation page I feel that it will be painted
It's a little awesome
, maybe it's just one line now I think it's only facing the direction I think it's profitable while looking at various places
I'll buy 4
I won't increase the number of cameras It's
like 3d after migration
That's what I said to Ahaa-kun at 8 o'clock, and that's how it's done, but the
concept is that it's a dying survival horror.
From now on, Bio 7 is loved by the left brain.  That's
a person who is doing a lot of horror-oriented works. That biohazard village is more of an
action element.
It's made to be chewy, so you
can fight a lot, right? The bereaved family's
Kanoko is okay, isn't it? It's going to be difficult, isn't it?
Even in the making of
The director says that the biohazard is
a horror movie that you play, but after all there is something that you can
touch, so
if you get used to it at the place a lot, it's definitely a little bit.  When you get used to
it, you can pay the code well.
Let's go to that head
.
It's the part of the stolen goods that doesn't come to me, so it's also decorated by the art director here,
but that picture book isn't it?  You can see that
it goes deeper into happiness and even with malformations
so that you can be guided, but it's like a coffee saga
, with that image of being inspired by the search line for that harsh child.  I think you can do it. One of the characters,
Mr. b
, is also for the human being, Mr. a. I think
that
all of me Sanu is a work that I can listen to
.
I want to see lisa winters until the end.
It
's one of the villages.
Volume 10 Passion is transmitted. I
also have an older sister.
[Music
] I want you to say it.
What kind of new monster do you want me to
be? What kind of monster is it? It's a monster or a loss.
I think that creature, I want you to be familiar with me now
, so it's better to call it by the nickname of Han Love
.
After this, a little more, if you can show me the incense that says how much that mountain of flowers loves the front, I
'll show you a
little like this.
Unfold the sound of  Because
I get angry with overseas employees, the two of them will grow and become rooted in the future
, so I also like Mr. Kano.
Thank you, Melos.
I really want you to enjoy it. Yes, no,
no, no, but my sister's family also came. It's an obstacle.
I can buy it without anything.  The making was also good, isn't
it? Well, I'm thinking about
what I can do today in the
company, and Mr. Kano, who has that kind of personality, will come in that month
.
Well
, that boss above us
has already bowed his head,
and I'm really wondering what kind of experience I would like to experience with that actual machine play,
but there are some conditions by all means.  Well,
regarding the game screen, it's a form that I will show only to Mr. Masaka who plays that well, but
that English will be used for those who are watching it, but
that voice and Mr. Kamo's super reaction
I want to show you that gameplay this time in a way that you can think about it and enjoy it.
Scoreler's new book
Is this okay? Thank you.
It seems that the screen you are playing will not be delivered to everyone
. Only Kano's reaction will be delivered.
I'll be waiting for a while,
the chunch is live, and it's live, and now it's like this
. Do you really have the enthusiasm to play?
Chinese food Ah
, all of the good things like that. It's not a high hurdle, but
if you're talking about everything else, let me know
the charm of the previous Maya Hatari 7 a little.
I wonder if you can prove it
. Hirano Well, I'm enthusiastic, but there
is a white place. This is the first time in the world.
Absolute fraction is  I want to give it up, I
'm really myself, what's the
world 8? It's the world's first.
I wonder if I'll get 8 answers while counting 8 seconds at midnight on that day. Well, it's okay to match it to my own site
. Then there's a wall
visit.  It's not a child, isn't
it? If it's from another company, it's more along the
bras along the gen.
I'm
commenting like a friend, and everyone said happily while saying the Rosie word.
Hahaha is the
second polyca person.
Please do it, I
'll go to each place 4 Prepare, even if
it's a great sense of accomplishment a Sweeping ship escort
Beautiful video system
I have to say one, so the sense of accomplishment is still on the way
. Wait for me on the 2nd. I wonder if I
've imagined it.  It's a grammar, isn't it?
6 Stupid Sayo Please have a remote control bomb.
I don't like that smell, Miyakasa
ck, and I'm a queen, isn't it? Many of them are
Oxmya Hiaros Natsuki, and Pete's now and repeat.
Ah
, I'm looking at it with the feeling of tps the most
. I think it's a problem at the time of criticism. It's a little far away.
It's serious, isn't it? It's a book, isn't it?
I really hate it, but that's it.  I'm sorry to say that the fans'
sound channel farm people don't want me to do it after him, so
please let me do it from the bottom of my heart
.  I
'm going to go where  I'm preparing for a pile of flowers on the monitor I'm
scared I'm scared I'm already scared The
babies are buried Yes Everyone I can't see the screen Solo I understand that place
Yes Please close your
lips and be gentle Outdoors with a mouth without lips
Yes
Then
Is it okay to go with the patient's signal right away
? Yes, it's called
Game Paster. I
'll go somehow with the Dawa
I bought. It's amazing today from the Buber lesson book
.  It's completely messy, but I managed to get it right now, but
I managed to beat it. Yes,
I can wear this anymore.  It's an item that never happens.
This scenery is 8 right now. The season is completely winter. It's a groovy place where snow is piled up
while it's a little old made of tall trees and
nobody lives here.
It
seems that Mr. Kita b is popular right now. Candidate 1 year ago. I
'm accepting it. Is it Johnny originally? It's a back cross.
I picked up the material, isn't it
? It's amazing, it's amazing, it's amazing,
isn't it? Turn around behind that,
it's
dangerous, it's dangerous, it's dangerous.
Issuance 8 isn't it? The
head road is ah. If the
body is over,
let's go. High championship 1 time
.
Of course, I
'm sure that I couldn't make
an enemy that I hadn't seen before.
It's
like a burn of weapons, but I'm hungry even though it's midwinter.
Let's do that.
Yes, I'm going there again, but I'm starting all the way
.
Increase It's the first time for me to say this I wonder if it's okay to say
which part or class I'm going to receive, isn't it okay?
It ’s a summer thing, is n’t it? It ’s amazing,
uh, that ’s why
it ’s been selected, and the platform is bad
. There is a step left. I think there is an entrance in the hut.
I'm sorry for turning to the right for a
moment. It's been from summer, so wait for Solos. It's right next to you, isn't it
?  It's a
type of game that sends Weapon City, isn't it? It's a different day.
Do you say the course?
Mura-ne,
it seems that you are trying to prevent the enemy from coming
. Is it blue? What is it
? kr on If it feels like kr on, you need a technique to sew.
And that's right, I'm saying that this can be done like this.
There's no reason for the second pizza, but
please find it. The only character isn't it.
Kabu
does is the scenery of this winter. It's a little redundant.
You can tell from the fact that the voice is constant, but
please enter the rest of the floor and the window.
Who was it when my husband told me on the 4th
? This is a swordsman.  Well, what's going on with
Boo Boo?
Yes, it's a little bad again.
It ’s
just a little bit, after all,
it ’s okay to use a weapon to say that,
it ’s a zombie, it ’s light, it ’s not just defeating the enemy.
Defeating enemies by using zombies
I see, it's like that, isn't it? That year, I
had you play that
kind of thing, and I did it once more, including that review.  I don't sell much even if I do it I don't like it because
I'm a producer who is talking I don't want to
change my car
Well, no, it ’s going to be over there. It ’s a little bit nice
, is n’t it? Now, go to the one with the light
.
I like it when
I'm done-
I still don't know why these enemies will appear here. Nazu is
just Maru, is
it working?
There was a look around, but there was no item there. Yes
, I got it properly. Yes,
I'll overcome this. Please go in front of that.
Even if you enter and close here, it's a little true. Actually, you can close
it here.  The soul of the zombies is looting again. 4 a
Enemy is now. This agent is a human being and there are items.
Please break this.
Recall to exceed this Yes, I'm down from the 2nd floor right now. I'm
completely
angry with zombies. I'm angry with Seki
.  Because the number of balls and
the number of zombies do not match, after
all, if you use a gimmick, etc.
You can go chan, right? The person has a local wing jaf in the theory. Even if it's
spicy, please search properly. Well, there are various items
. Now she's off the ladder. She's in the
countryside of Ogura.
Ah, that's it, the curtain is completely covert, covert, touching, and
now it's coming out at the opening.
It
seems that I'm not the only person who is alive anymore. Is
it possible to do an accelerator chain
? It's a very narrow work tomorrow. It's not good if you stop.
There was a dangerous seedless child
, please get out early. There was something like a funk role.
Wow
ioc, but please wear this.
Pete is frustrated. I'm thinking about the actual situation in the morning.  I'm excited, I'm
trying to escape from this village completely right now.
You're completely in the shape of a defeat. You're in this Murata Hula.
I'm
trying to do it, but yeah, it's a worm tooth, please do your best I still don't know if the other side is the exit
.  4 It's hard to turn into a fire. 4
What happened to the child who was on fire in the fun village? It's
just getting deeper for some reason.
Go Miburoya-san, do your best, do your best,
before the movement,
once,
once, away from 1, I can't beat this. That child is running around in the village.
Now, Imamura is really amazing.  And some of the enemies had forgotten it, and
I was worried about it as a whole. There was an inside
.
What should I do? Spina-
san Mina-san I'm going to survive now.
Let's do our best. This mission. Please survive for the time being. Such a
reckless seed.
There are many enemies anyway  Anyway, there are a lot of enemies, but I feel like I'm reading the air and seeing off a little. There
's
no recovery. Feed-san Do
n't rely on Pete-The
company is Suppy Town.
Is it a
zone
game? Even if this aim is decided well,
it's not an investment 9 member. It's
a dive to work. Please stick a little more.
After starting here, there is a sense of life.
What happened to the herbs?
Maybe
if you go to the owner of the house in
Wiltdo, you might be able to hit it a little safer. Wait a minute
.
There are many of the biggest guys in this village.
What's this swaying, swaying Pete-san was
the king who gave me a hint but ignored it?
Something in this house Purple flower
Air guy Ah-
I didn't do it, it was done.
Yeah,
it was a great play, angry, this is a bit slow, no, that's right
. It's
true that the final stage of the game has a lot of action
elements.  It's
true that even the unprecedented herbs have this kanji character
. I want to
escape. If I escape there, it's actually a front wrap.
It feels good.  It's still a
touching part. I
really think the item is so high that I can defeat the enemy and get the item.
Maybe that's right. Well, I'd like to see that area really change depending on that play style,
but
that's the item that the enemy drops, as if it was really live now, and it
's a craft.  Yeah
, it's possible to make something like that, such as ammunition, so
I
'd like to see the reaction on twitter, I wonder if it's a blade.
I think I want you to get it now, isn't it
? Yeah Yoda is really interesting? It
really feels like that powder is in
it.  I don't know what's going on, so I'm worried about items and materials everywhere,
and I can't beat them. I can jump over the fire of the door shop,
windows, and cherry blossoms.
That's right.  After all, it's a crazy survival horror
. That theme is set. If you don't do various things in a hurry, you can
wait and
walk around and pick up 7 items.
I want to do something interesting.
First of all, I'm already doing it. I want to do more. I want to do more urine.
It ’s okay, take the
initiative, and I ’
ll kill you a lot.
Even Pete gets very angry, but I don't run
out of seats. Ah, ah, so this is no good. Chocolat-chan.
Well
, I'd like to tell you about the majors.
Since there are more movable parts than this, it is possible to reproduce all the poses in the game
. The
release date will be released worldwide in the spring of 2021, so please check the official website etc. for
details
Yes, there are so many moving parts  There are many places, but
if you do this child,
what kind of pose will you take for Sati's ramen
?  Click here for the city council
Leon and Claire's 1/4 statue of Resident Evil 2 from Prime 1 Studio
are now available. The in-
game poses are faithfully reproduced and the overwhelming detail is a must-see.
This is also
scheduled to start accepting orders from the fall of 2020. For more information, please check the online store of Prime 1 Studio
.
This is also good.
The capcom Tokyo Game Show 2020 online shop is
accepting pre-orders for the biohazard village t-shirt and light
bruzon.  There is one, you know,
Apro-san also has a two-color development with a professional name of black,
but
he's also the one in front of Hirai-san, isn't it? T-shirt and East Bruzon
Bruzon  This is navy
Yes Yes
There is a big logo on the back
t The black that the shirt looks black and the black that the charcoal is fashionable and has a high range are
also
cool, but the
charcoal is also
good If there are three aircraft, it's a dog or
that  I think that you can
prepare it if you can call it, but that's it
, please check it out in the form of love,
thank you. Thank you for the related information.
There may be a mon who wants a product, but if Capcom's
game is played before the war, talk to me,
who is your father? What do you really think?
It's okay to put
it in. Yes
, so this corner is getting closer to the exposure, but is it the end?
There is one thing I would like to ask you. Actually, today we are
running a keyword campaign where 100 people watching this Capcom tds Live 2020 live
will win a quo card page of 500 yen by lottery.
Then, I would like to ask Mr. Kano, the second keyword,
but
is it really okay?
Then, the second keyword,
Mr. Kano, please.
It's a little more predictive
. It's okay to say that it's Go Nagai because I've been in it for a long time.
I'd like everyone to think about it, but even in magazines, the second one is a long stick, but
from my point of view it's short, but
I think each person has it.
However, please connect the three keywords based on the keywords that will be announced at the end of the program today and
fight for the application form on the Capcom tgs Live 2020 special site
. Let's go to 100 people by lottery Card page 500  The
deadline is 9 am tomorrow 28th, so
please take a look at
it until the end. Thank
you for your application
.  Thank you for your child. Thank you for not enjoying this. It's
about time.
Why is it? Well, to everyone who sees this. Message from Kanno-kun.
Looking at the pet from the front, long balls and toro settings First of all,
Bomb represents this bekko and is for the sake of Mun
.
I've received a lot of information, so I'll clear the Hokusonosei simulated obstacles for fun. There's also Haya no Sora and
Beer.
Hey, I
'd like to ask you too. It's a lie. Lightly dlc or
Download
can be done with c 4 Care Iyaha-chan. It's a picture content that can be done with that care-
chan.
Okay, is it the way to continue after clearing the main story and making one?
It's a lot of fun, isn't
it? You can play in the morning. Yes, there's a
mini-game-like thing. That episobic, then I'll brew the last
one.  That's right, I want you to do it. I wonder if
there are 100 different types. 41
I want you to cover this work. I hope you enjoy it.
Thank you Kyomoto. Thank you very much
.  Thank you so much. If you've fallen into the end,
you can give your impressions of today to the viewers with b now.
I don't know if I said love is easy 4 It's too easy I'll make this easier Thank you Ah
Ah
, my
wife seems to be expensive, right? I'm not good at English in the future.
Thank you for watching. I think
that Mr. Kano's super reaction made me feel a part of the fun of the village now
.
The development team.  We are
working hard to make the village a better work.
We would like to deliver that gameplay to everyone as soon as we are ready
, so please wait for a while.
The 25th anniversary of Resident Evil.  Thanks to all of those fans, we will be welcoming next year
.
Well, not only games, but also that movies,
attractions, goods, and so on.
I think it's really thanks to everyone who supports Resident Evil.
I would like to thank the
producer Kobayashi, who introduced me earlier.
I would like to continue to liven up the development of the 25th anniversary of the beginning of Resident Evil infinite Darkness, so please continue to support Capcom after the hazard series
. Thank you very much for today
.
Let's look forward to future information Yes Biohazard Village Kanda Producer p,
Producer and Guest Hide Kano  Thank you very much for being Takashi. Thank you. We
will
continue to deliver related information.
Yes, we will deliver various information about God now.
I would like to continue to send it to you at Capcom tv.
Thank you for your cooperation
.  It's a nicknamed tone. It's
amazing. This was just announced and it
was exciting even on twitter. Congratulations
.
Thank you for seeing this
.  Download versions of various titles are being held under the title of Capcom tgs Live 2020 Commemorative
Sale. Everyone, Biohazard re 3 is on sale at
half price.
I painted it on this occasion. How many laps
did it take? Walking 3 episodes
8 weeks
It's amazing 9 battles. Is it okay to clear this game once
?  You can raise it and change that
item, so if you
do Nakata over and over again, you can go up to about 8 times, isn't it
? Also, the original version of Resident Evil iii Land Escape released in 1999.
Costumes with the motif of
Jill & Carlos Classic Costume Pack can also be purchased at a low price, so I think it's a good idea
to put it in
and challenge the survival of Raccoon City with a fresh feeling of walking at that time.
Yeah, I'd like you to do it.
Yeah
, it's all about Biohazard Village, which I introduced earlier. Biohazard 7
Resident Evil can also
be high-class for 885 yen + tax. It's a
very slow price.
I'm doing a cloud of flowers in Taizan. If you
want to do that, I'd really like to ask you, but
Biohazard Village is a sequel to Resident Evil 7 and a good building.  Ah, before doing the village, I
definitely want you to play this, so it's really fun.
There are so many things that overturn the first image of the cheering ingredients, so I'd like you to do it. Thank you
.  Mega Man Eleven The gear of fate and the wolf superb view version are cheaper, and
the Monster Hunter Double Cross of Nintendo Switch is also cheaper. If
you want to know the overlay
, please check the Capcom tgs Live 2020 special site now.  Next,
a special site is open for a limited time.
e Capcom Tokyo Game Show 2020 Online Shop Information
Yes First of all, the introduction of Monster Hunter Rise's t-shirt, which was introduced yesterday, isn't
it? The main monster is now guarded.  We have two types of fabrics, one based
on the black fabric with a terrifying design and
the white fabric with the cute Otomo Airou and Otomo designed by Ruku
.
One is a
cute
Airou and
two light
white fabrics
[Music].
Yes, the details are on the screen right now, so if you want to buy this, you can access it from the qr code right now
. Thank you.
Well, there is also a Parker that will be active in the coming season.
Felyne has a cute and deformed color illustration printed on the chest
. It's also on the back.
I have a brush-style illustration printed on the hem.
This front 4 a
Is it a hem on
the back? It's just the back on the right. It's bright and cute.
Yes, it's
stupid.
If you
attach a cat's acrylic key holder to the tote bag, it will surely double the cuteness, so this is a little later or I'm going back to a fool
Shirako Yeah
, it's Airou.
I think it's okay to use it as an eco bag, but I'll
show you the key to open it.  You
can see it's
clear. The
lighting is reflected and it's a sound.
Pre will donate it, but this time the
monster hunters and others are in the style of Izu brush persimmon, so it's okay to put on a mars
.
It is
a related product of Fighter 5 Champion Edition.
Eh Street Fighter 5-40 Introducing a new art t-shirt with characters drawn
.
Capcom's illustrator flight is officially drawn with 40 characters of Street Fighter 5
drawn by sushi.  It's an original t-shirt. I
don't know if the green part is painted or not, but there are some parts that are missing, but
I have a feeling that it's missing so far.  That's right.
Yes,
by all means, and Capcom's illustrator flight is also available.
Street Fighter 5 E-Capcom Limited Art is also available in the original Parker with a line
design. Simple design of sticks and buttons on the chest.
It's a slender and thin all-purpose zip-up parker that designed the characters and art of Street Fighter 5 on the back
. It seems that you should use this when you enter the room in the summer.  This
is the last product here. This is
the introduction of the Street Fighter Series Pixel Art Cap.
One point of Poppo Chara And the back is a one-
size-fits-all cap with
the Street Fighter logo embroidered.  It's cute, isn't it
? It looks simple at first glance, but the characters are studded on the back of the brim with a monochrome design
. This can make a difference to rivals
.
Thank you for your reservation. Thank you for your mother love. Various other goods are on sale, so please see the E-
Capcom Tokyo Game Show 2020 online shop for details.
Let's go steadily. The following information is
available at Netflix, which provides the world's largest online entertainment service.  Ginal
Anime Series Dragon's Dogma is being
exclusively distributed worldwide. Please see here first.
Pure Jua Mansudae se Chawa
Stars Live Pale One Floor Hands dears
says
play
so Wharf survive I was
supporting
you.
Sazamachi is said to be an ethnic group.
Lever wants I still have flowers before
rg Conte Fund s Character Deer cfbd Julanderby 2 I have
money
[Music]
face 10 minutes japan version f
Whichever mom I used to send
hey